how's it going brother - prayer back
welcome to crash'd ESIC part 2 you rose
really liked it I really liked it
let's like it together I guess that's
some we left off on level 15 euro but
cannot touch the ground you must crush
the finish line
what the [ __ ] it says easy but naturally
we shall load our Martha Stewart and
let's just go go go Martha you [ __ ] I
Bob it looks like we're gonna have to do
something about this alright sly this
nut [ __ ]
oh god damn it Bob you're not even going
forward are you it is going forward
she's not for long there we go okay all
right here comes the real check
hahahahahaha what is what is that okay
I'm sure this will go great it's not
going for it's like shaking forward holy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I swear to god this is the best one I
ever made this piece of [ __ ] working oh
god what the [ __ ] these camera angles
man oh god okay here comes ah ah get
back on track [ __ ] we can actually do
this with this piece of junk it's not
the fastest one that wins the race it's
the one that shakes the most booty how
did this work the last time can someone
explain out now it's sorry once it stops
shaking that booty it starts to work in
that hole a more power
oh stop shaking so [ __ ] much oh god
it's working okay here comes it's all up
to piloting skills from now on it'd be
great if I can [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh it's Bob Fitness Bob's Bob you dick
you've been sabotaging me Bob this is
not gonna work in a million [ __ ]
years sometimes I wonder why I even
tried holy [ __ ] Bob looks so like
whatever
Bobby's actually Stephen Hawking okay
focus focus that is not focusing now
come on
Martha Stewart 3po Noi oh I forgot to
put one of the wheels ha ha ha ha we can
still do it never give up okay maybe
give up sometime ok this is actually
pretty [ __ ] stable let's see how
these [ __ ] handles in not that great
bobby-boo I will give you ice cream I
will give you ice cream if you make this
I will give you ice cream from my
[ __ ]
chocolate flavor you piece of [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
my god dumb skills we are [ __ ]
sliding into that [ __ ] hole Bob Bob
Bob Bob if you stop now Bob I will kill
you
stop with the lag ah-ah-ah
thank God that shit's a vice and lagging
and understand what target plot to again
it was fine with one well luckily we say
Martha Stewart those aerodynamics bro
right so this obviously needs more
rockets go haha this thing is very
energy-efficient man come on Bob it was
that it splice too good look at that I
came in like a Bobby Bob
oh that's regulations pose
oh my god level what let's load our baby
really room Q did this on the first try
are you serious hell yeah the difficulty
levels are just fog robot must stop I'm
sorry what up there what the hell that
is only possible when all fails you got
a choke on dick
what the hell this is balance it like a
balance my [ __ ] here we go havoc
that's never gonna work
[ __ ] physics man I just I just don't
think there's any [ __ ] way I'm gonna
do that one alright let's do 19 easy
checkpoint Robert must pass through each
checkpoint that's kind of easy right
these are so easy oh now that's smooth
finish all right easy next one
Dada Pokemon look scary what is it oh
hey what was that alright another
challenge for RIM kick
oh god you Bob Lee piece of [ __ ] did I
tell you it stopped not flipping Bob
front slip to victory
blood lift yeah
it'd be great affair I don't know this
[ __ ] thing had brakes I goddamn eat
there he goes with these [ __ ] front
flips again why did I tell you about the
front flips Bob's that enough back away
for you [ __ ]
oh god a [ __ ] my ass got stuck I don't
have no idea why I thought this was a
good idea okay so far what no okay new
new battle plan man I should be hired by
[ __ ] car companies and [ __ ] oh look
at that
oh no front flip doesn't matter cuz I
can ride either way baby
I ride either damn it can sail the wet
getting some crazy [ __ ] ideas here
but I'm like Leonardo da Vinci what what
happens up there what is that
gah Bob what is he doing that
oh god stop shaking what the [ __ ] Oh
what for Jesus I can't damage Jesus
carry your cross all the way to victory
oh my god yes okay we did it I don't
know how no one knows how god this game
is fun
Rowan must pass through each other each
checkpoint you must crush finish oh god
it may not be the most stable thing in
the world we got our goddamnit a
definite isn't I gotta go through all
those checkpoints are you synereo well
this obviously needs to wear a command
okay I think this is pretty good
you think about it holy [ __ ] it's
working why is it working no one else
it's gonna flip over any minute oh god
no no another shitty idea by me I don't
worry about it Bob if we make this I
will not poop on you tonight I wouldn't
make this [ __ ] up Bob but the camera
angles man why why do you why do I have
to guess
I can't control it turn that ice yeah
yeah you're doing that thing again where
I can't what what what's Oh still in the
game baby
still in - gosh don't don't change God
ha ha ha oh god we have too much pee now
Oh ain't no camera angles gonna stop me
sure walls wave maybe walls ah for
[ __ ] sake awful huh night you camera
angles
you [ __ ] oh it's like lag camera
angles and everything it's just
goddammit goddammit go Bob
well that looks fun okay there's one
that we haven't finished
so let's [ __ ] try this is this dumb
how in the [ __ ] name of [ __ ] are you
gonna end up there it's right above us
carry on my ray where's Bob the cherries
suck Enya um I have an idea
it's stupid enough to actually work what
are you telling me I can click myself
why did you tell me dance it now I play
the entire game
Oh ha ha ha
what are you going Bob oh god oh no oh
this is gonna be horrible we got
something good going here maybe not [ __ ]
Bob Bob this is ah easy easy like your
mom
on Saturdays when she's filling mom that
rollerball [ __ ] [ __ ] don't [ __ ] up
Oh aah aah
ha ha
stay stay stay hey we got that [ __ ]
perfect landing ha ha that was all the
levels might it's hard so that's it for
crash tastic it's a really fun game
hope you enjoyed leave it like if you
did I really appreciate it I heard you
wrote a suggested Kerbal space program
which seems kind of similar no I'm not
sure let me know if you want me to play
that next hit subscribe to come rule
today I see you Bruce in the next one
say awesome love you